Okay Michael, so let's see if we can, work
together to deal with this minor triffle of a problem,
that ,ah, you've observed with my cooling algorithm, okay.
So, here's some data, it's a graph and you see
here's a y axis and here's an x axis,
and each of these points, represents a house, on this
map, which I'm, I'm cleverly, using in the background. [CROSSTALK]
And, you'll notice, that each of the dots is colored.
I'm going to say that red represents, really expensive houses, blue
represents, moderately expensive houses, and
green represents, really inexpensive houses. Okay?
>> Okay, where is this?
>> Where is this? Oh, this is Georgia Tech,
as you can tell because, it says Georgia Tech.
>> Oh, I see it now.
>> Okay. So, here's what I want you to do. using machine learning.
I want you to look at all of this data, and then
I want you to tell me, for these little black dots, whether they
are really expensive, moderately expensive or, or inexpensive. But ,I want you
to do it, using something like the technique that we talked about before.
>> Okay?
>> So, let's look at this little dot, over here. Which,
by the way, I want to point out. this little black
dot here by the US Post Office, underneath the rightmost ,e
,over here, is not a point in our data base. But
I think by staring at this, you might be able to come up
with a reasonable guess, about whether
it is moderately expensive, expensive, or inexpensive.
>> Okay, yeah. I think, this is a helpful, example, because, now I see
that it does kind of make sense, especially, in this context, to think of
the geometric location, as actually being a
very useful attribute for deciding how to
label the new points. So, that black point that you've pointed out, is in the
part of the neighborhood, that has a green dot
in it. Like, the nearest dot to it, seems like
a pretty good guess as to what, what the value
of that house might be, so I'm going to guess green.
>> Yes, and I think ,you would be right. And I like the word that you
used there. You talked about, its nearest neighbor,
so I like that. I'm going to write that down.
Neighbor, okay. So, I'm going to look at my
nearest neighbor. Well let's see if this works,
for another point. Let's look at another point,
that's near an, e, let's see, the first e
over here. This little black point, over here. What do you think? If I,
if I looked at my nearest neighbor, what would I, what would I guess?
>> Yeah, this one seems really clear. It's, it's
surrounded by red. It's in the red part of town.
>> So, you're guessing, the output is then, purple? [LAUGH]
>> No, I'm going with red.
>> Yes, and I think that that makes perfect sense. So, this is pretty
cool. If I have a point that's not in my database ,but, I still,
by looking at my nearest neighbour, can, sort of figure out ,ah,
what the actual value should be. So, there we have solved, the problem.
>> Yes, seems like a pretty good role.
>> Yeah, just look at your nearest neighbour and you are
done. There, so, boom. There is nothing else for you to do.
>> Yeah, except that you didn't do all of the houses yet.
>> Okay, well, what did I miss?
>> The one in the middle and [CROSSTALK]
I'm wondering, if maybe you did that on purpose,
because, this one has some issues.
>> What are its issues? Besides being too, near 10th Street?
>> well, yeah, apart from that it doesn't
really have any very close neighbors ,on the,
on the map. So the closest that you get, is, I don't know, maybe that red one?
>> Maybe.
>> But I would be really, I'd be very wary
of just using that as my guess, because, it's also pretty
darn close to a bluepoint.
>> Yeah.
>> And also not so, far from the green point.
>> That's a good point. So, this whole nearest neighbor thing
doesn't quite work, in this case when you got a bunch
of neighbors that are saying different things. And they are kind
of close to you. So, any clever way we might around this?
>> I would say, move the black dot, to,
>> No, no, no, no, we are not allowed that before.
>> No? Okay, right it
seems, it seems, like it would be helpful.
>> No, no, they are federal laws ,against interesting.
>> I was going to say, yeah, so, alright So, short of
that, maybe ,we just need to look at a bigger context?
>> Ahh, that makes sense. So, you're saying my little nearest neighbor
thing, sort of worked ,but the problem was I started out with examples
,that were, you know, very clearly in a neighborhood, and now I'm
in a place where I'm not so sure about the neighborhood, so I
should let I should look at more of my neighbors, than just the closest one.